You know you've made it as an icon in the business
when you have your own Lego figure.
I think we'll start with yours, Kumail.
Can we take a look at it?
And you assess what you think of your Lego figurine.
[Kumail] Well.
(audience exclaiming)
[Conan] Are you the one with the selfie stick there?
[Kumail] I'm both of 'em.
[Conan] Oh you're both of them?
[Kumail] So like that they were like sort of based
on your character, so he's gonna wear
a douchey orange scarf.
(audience laughing)
And a selfie stick.
And I also like that, my weapon is a chain
with a massive blade at the end.
It's not like a fun kids weapon.
It's, like, you can like murder with this.
(audience laughing)
And then Olivia, let's take a look at yours.
I think it's up there.
I'm just curious if your family is proud
that you have a Lego.
My mom is so funny.
When I told her she was like,
"Oh, that's so great, you do voice in Lego movie."
"Do they paint you yellow in person?"
And I was like, "No, what?"
(audience laughing)
I go, "Mom, it's a voiceover."
She goes, "I know.
"You know, to help you get into character,
they paint you yellow."
And I was like, "Mom, that's the stupidest thing
you have ever said."
(audience laughing)
"Stop calling me."
[Conan] Never talk to me again.
And I haven't spoken to her since.
Yeah, good.
(audience laughing)
Always nice to end on a happy note.
And Zach, let's take a look at yours.
I'm just curious if you like what they've done.
(audience laughing)
I don't even know what's happening here.
(laughing)
What's happening with your character?
Evidently he's a prep school student by day
and a snow sniper by night.
(audience laughing)
I was excited to have a Lego that I was the voice of
but the truth is like,
I used to Playmobil, which were like these joyless,
I loved them so much, but it's,
basically all the sets are just
people doing things in like European welfare states
where it's like guys mowing traffic islands
and checking water meters.
Yes, yes, I remember those.
They were like very Scandinavian.
Yeah, exactly.
It's like Legos except they all have excellent healthcare.
Exactly.
(laughing)
I also loved, I was obsessed with
American Girl dolls 'cause my sister had
American Girl dolls and my parents would read her
the accompanying books.
What I would really like to be
is the voice of one of the American Girl dolls.
(laughing)
What?
Yeah.
Just tell me what era American Girl--
Samantha, the Victorian one, duh.
(laughing)